all right Cheyenne Cheyenne where you
from originally
where'd you grow up Ohio what part of
Ohio Columbus tell me buddy shopping get
both your parents and your kid uh no but
my parents weren't around that much
there are less drugs like involved you
see your parents bring the drug
yeah my parents still are like my real
dad recently died so like last 17 I had
to find out hard way but my mom still
around huh Oh Freddy god I wish you'd
just died but no can't wish that on your
mother this old person you have hole do
you know I'm 20 and how long you been
living on the street for years how was
the rest of your childhood if you passed
away with I 17 my brother had just
turned nine
that time how was your childhood pretty
city huh my mom let my people in molest
me so she could get her drugs for free
so I was getting raped by my family at
the age of seven I came down here I
found out she was talking dude again so
I just volunteered and started doing it
for her I started selling my body for so
that's how it was I don't do that
anymore I usually ask for money if I
need it yeah sometimes depends on who
they are sir what's this piece of [ __ ]
don't care but I'm taking the drugs then
we'll help you out when did you come to
West Virginia when I turned 18 got out
of jail huh I was in Ohio I can't I got
out of jail in Ohio I came down here I
got tired of getting in trouble my mom
called me asked me to come down here and
I did yeah yeah my mom was actually on
Locust right up here that's rude sir huh
she's pretty close by but just doesn't
like entering the door for me it's for
some reason and so are you
sleep at night what do you do I usually
go to a bandeau
Ike abandoned house where nobody lives
but people like trashed it and I left
and drugs are part of your life as well
yeah which we struggle to use heroin
meth weed anything get my hands on
honestly those using drugs kind of help
you forget about what happened as a
child yeah everyone left my problems
people ask me well I did so much because
I'm running away from my problems
throwing away from my pass helps me
forget like stuff that happened sort of
like people that pissed me off during
the day makes me forget about everything
makes me not want to kill myself jump
off the bridge yeah but jumped off a
bridge Saturday it's most likely all the
time like people like just spread rumors
around this town not true you know and
call it back or somebody's 20 years old
her life and has torn your old scared to
death walk a straight as now I'm never
afraid to walk the streets I had to have
that five or six people with me to walk
the streets because people have tried to
come behind me and kill me yeah very
like I prayed to God that my brother
does not come down here when he gets
older that's I don't want to find him
dead in a ditch from drugs or dead with
a needle out of his arm that's my
brother I looked out for a much younger
that's all that's all I had to growing
up with my brother we had each other
with a half parents they cared buy drugs
yeah about us no so we're a very rural
part of the country you can still find
drugs like heroin and crystal meth here
yeah I can find them but I can find that
[ __ ] like that better in sales I came
here in Clarksburg honestly Clarksburg
so drives to coronavirus prices went up
on everything
yeah and sale on but I rather like in
Salem I don't do anything else other
than weed I don't [ __ ] with anything
else I don't have a needle so I don't
shoot
my heroin like my dude that I'm living
with I would have told me he'd rather
see me with then anybody else here since
while he's in jail he doesn't believe
here when his mom died a heroin she ID'd
and he found her and he's all in 26 like
he told her that he doesn't want to talk
to her because of the fucked-up [ __ ]
she's doing and she died like in he
didn't get say goodbye or anything till
I kind of how I should feel I didn't get
say goodbye to my dad actually so I know
how I feel like I I try to do as much as
I can to die sometimes I'd be shocked
six times already because I did on four
bunts a heroin by myself I did four
times a day I did I don't do that much
anymore bad what's the hardest part of
this lifestyle living drugs getting by
trying to figure out where the next meal
comes from way to sleep Evan was gonna
try to kill you if people's giving you a
fake stuff if people was ratting on you
wearing a wire on you that's what the
worst thing is happening here
I had a hotshot earth insulin just
insulin
I turned grid had to be rushed to a
hospital hot shot somebody put something
in your yeah but my heart was just
insulin I'm not diabetic so kind of kind
of uh killed me
two boys already and uh one on the way
oh you're pregnant yeah about four
months side the guess is say I don't eat
that much like on I have really bad the
eating disorder and like I get so strung
out on dope like I don't need that much
like I don't like I can't say here do
dope right now and I give two [ __ ] like
[ __ ] this [ __ ] that I got the five
freaking about my childhood that's all I
care about
yeah I run from my problems it helps me
forget about being a calf I start
thinking was something from my childhood
I do some drug helps me like I freakin
about what I was thinking like I forgot
was thinking about and I think for hours
about what I was thinking about and I
finally found out what I was thinking
about not doing drug again pretty good
about it again they're gone parents want
to get I'm getting ready to go to a
forty day detox and Parkersburg as soon
as I go back to my friends and help me
get in ain't at that hopefully hopefully
I can stay through all this detox not
come home one day did you try to do
anything before I was clean for three
months also shooting and everything else
before I came back to town three days
ago I was on doing weed and kind of
thought about something from my past and
people were bringing it up and kind of
got kind of got volta meth and heroin
shooting up again like it lasted five
seconds like when you see a person put a
needle in their arm it makes me wonder
so bad and I asked that person for a
point and I shot myself up like five or
six times and got to the point where I
didn't know where I was like I was lost
I was shaking I was crying but people
were trying to come kill me like I said
I didn't know where I was huh I woke up
overnight saying somebody that wound a
sandwich turns up at the door and
there's nobody like huh like you get to
a point where you see you go long
Wendy's trail you see dead bodies for
people to kill people you see you
discover heads and trash bags body parts
everywhere find her out a couple like
months ago my friend died because a drug
deal gone wrong he wasn't supposed to be
at the place he was at time and well
wrong and they killed him not person
that God
so yeah you find dead bodies you find
points to find heads you find people
with head chopped off people around my
age dying it's hard especially if you
know the person very well your best
friend gets shot by her freaking her
foster dad that loves her that has a
frickin crush on her and I want to be
with her get shot lose his life over
something stupid at least a three year
old daughter behind he/she sees spirits
so she sees her dad and says mommy daddy
said he will be okay you don't see that
on a typical child typical child doesn't
see that
so yeah it starts plugged up
I'm not forget to go back to Ohio
sideburns to serve down there and
hopefully I can go home after I go and
try go get help and my foster parents
hopefully let me come back home because
I don't want to be in this state no more
I don't want nowhere near West Virginia
I don't care where I go as long as as
far away from here I don't care if I go
to prison some other country as long as
this far away from here you know what I
mean like those talents [ __ ] that fun
dead bodies and [ __ ] like that you
shouldn't have to find that on a daily
basis because people [ __ ] up people wear
wires on people then that person finds
out you don't find that person referred
next day you won't find him alive see
there in the river on a trail huh I will
not walk among those trails there and
they in the morning and night I don't
care I hope he will not see me down
there unless I have a good strong
muscular me and that's about this big
round maybe somebody with a knife a
freaking conscious thing machete gun
something like my friend had to walk
with me all day one day to collect drugs
cuz I so scared and his own person at
night I don't carry that stuff with me
cuz cops don't like me Canton I've
chosen without pisses me off watch out
swinging that you'll get for a
conviction of prostitution or drug use
actually a cop has bailed me out of
prostitution nine times but that's cause
my boyfriend dose drugs to him like the
cops around here buy drugs
honestly they do I thought I had chief
police buy drugs for me and my boyfriend
like it's bad huh like they go around
every Thursday at night at Wendy's and
gift C is freakin drugs out of the car
like it's bad and you see that [ __ ]
you're like what the [ __ ] going on in
this world today my god what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is going on you know what
I mean like what [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] are these cops doing I
don't they know they could wish stop oh
no we won't lose your job so no it's
okay we could do this but if they do
that freaking wrestling they'll go to
prison they'll do that the time but us
we could just get away with this cool
uh-huh
just like freakin cops are now with
white cops are now killing black people
nowadays like literally I guess the
chief police after they found
laughter George they killed George Ford
I guess he retired because he was black
cop a black chief he's probably thinking
whether these freakin cops gonna do me
I'm black too huh it's struggles real
huh let me tell you my mom never taught
me about the drugs like him down here I
have learned by myself struggles real
uh-huh
it ain't no games and ain't oh yeah you
can do this you can rip me off you could
give me fake [ __ ] I not know sometimes
yeah you don't know it's fake [ __ ] until
you do it and you're going like this and
your season and your fall to the floor
or you can't stop breathing that's how
you know it's fake huh I woke up to
Chris slapping me in the face like five
six times when they excited he had he
like ice on my back when yo D off a
heroin or anything you roll over
somebody roll you on your side you start
breathing again everything's okay he
owed heed from me Simon Thomas I thought
I'd do it to him scared to [ __ ] out him
like he scared me
huh like he had like five or six cops at
our house and walked downstairs
perfectly fine I said oh [ __ ] no that's
that's [ __ ] up ha ha ha how could he
come from
Oh Dean the walking downstairs pretty
quickly bond you think I didn't think
you'd show back up I should have knock
on that door
I said that's like an ego see chris is a
cook good luck getting on as if it's
still breathing by the time we get there
you think what do you mean that's like
this just long story [ __ ] he's like now
what
that's the Quixote that's on home why do
you think I came home no I said here
strung out but I think I might be strung
up but here just over DT bro mm-hmm
like his sister knows how to wake him up
like when stuff like that happens I
never did until like somebody actually
physically told me that you had to roll
over on their side that's like he's like
300 pounds ha [ __ ] about who's supposed
to roll him over as a guy I do I'm not
that big deal with him and to help him
roll over every time I have him on his
side he likes to go back on his back
when he's trying to die on purpose
his son walked in it's like dad my voice
air foam coming out of your mouth I said
oh I think you better get him out it's
like you better get him out in this room
now I think I'm gonna freakin foot moves
thank you better get him out it's like a
six-year-old should not have to see that
I had to see your dad choking on his own
vomit on purpose yeah he's choking on
his own vomit on purpose to die cuz this
son comes in next day when I came back
dad why did I see phone come out of your
mouth you need to stop the stupid [ __ ]
and you get off of it and stop your bro
on us back there for one a chance to
have less kids backing it stop I stirred
phone come around your mouth while were
you go like this why worry about dying
I said no I said get him out to ask Ryan
I think you're pretty game [ __ ] out now
said you don't get him the [ __ ] out I
swear to god I'll [ __ ] through all like
I felt kill his whole family because
they were a sick sholde see that boy
they know what's happened he's four he's
not gonna know it's not gonna understand
it his six-year-old knows a little more
than he should because his green that he
likes to run the mouth I tell him what
everybody does in the house
so where y'all with saying that made me
flip the [ __ ] out like my brother didn't
see that growing up like you he was just
born so he kind of got lucky there it
he doesn't know who his real mom is or
who is real that is I do I don't know
him I hold real family is he
doesn't you feel like you might be
following in your parents footsteps yeah
I think it's mom did drugs
why not like me try it but if I shoot up
and my mom sees marks my arm
why shouldn't I bla bla bla bla and she
she said serious yeah I've done it it's
like if you don't know what makes what
why can't I do it I think you've done it
so why can I do it
you've done it too I say so you can't
sit here and judge me I think you can't
stay here no judgment for what I've done
what do you do it to like Chris one that
he had a point
oh no it's like phew much you can go to
in bathroom any month right here is in
my montage he's a gift month you can go
do the shot in your mom's bathroom
tell him I said I'm not doing a shot in
the mosque I think it's disrespectful
it's my mom's house that's actually my
aunt's house
so that's disrespectful towards my mom
my stepdad my aunt my uncle do do [ __ ]
like that in their house I was like I'm
not doing it it's like your house who
gets [ __ ]
voice I'm fine needles anyway huh he's
like they will sort of find their own
yeah we started finding those picking
them up because Chris sister just leaves
them all the way around and had to
picking big white bowl squirts or blood
in it and dry blood like every way like
it makes me throw up huh like it
disgusts me hmm like I am sorry drugs
and toughen up my mom was hustling and
now Shawn met in our house I asked her
every day why are these people were in
there now she's like oh I'm just telling
weed no I found out the hard way that
she's done a myth so that's what got me
started it was payback for line huh I
think [ __ ] payback you lie to me cuz
I do so you don't want me to do I've
heard how I ever shut up
she's found track Marcum
all there huh however you 2000 just
recently like recently recently like
seven months ago maybe but I've still
been twenty huh so I see it found track
my comic first time I should shoot up
track mark here check mark there
that's that matter for about the most
for the Sam Barker necklace I'm marking
her neck
I think poked myself with wire thing me
too
sorry my bad mm-hmm hey no no no this
Bruce there too and there's big freaking
it's felt like you actually the only
missed the shot I was like I don't want
to talk about oh I will just talk about
I wouldn't talk about you shut up blah
blah I said I didn't do it Mike had
somebody else do it for me see girl my
girl says Chris is like I'm not Tony
names I'll tell you who helps me with my
stuff it's not your business
it's like you told on me for Eva I did
me out I'm freaking recording and made
me go to jail mentioning names around
you I'll tell her where I'm at when I'm
somewhere she's funny
I tell her I'll meet her halfway I will
not let her know what house I'm at whose
house I meant salamat you halfway
mhm I meet you halfway you'll see me
halfway there I think you pissed me off
bro I'm not showing up like one day on
my birthday all she cared about getting
drugs thank you yes yeah they go slow
you
you